hey Jonathan we were told Chris what's
up buddy sit down man good right - just
talking about a guy who got arrested for
being naked and hard in Florida because
the rain gives him an erection see the
naked is one thing but the heart takes
it to the the bad level also he was
carrying a bottle of cooking oil with
him but does that make you admire him a
little bit that he can maintain an
erection outside in the rain walking
around there's something admirable that
that's real concentration like you know
early on in jackass
if you were in a van and you heard
pontius go uh-huh and you would look
back and he would be good he would be
masturbating in the back of the van and
why oh I don't know
- just but you would see all the guys
jumping over the seats cuz he could
finish - oh my god yeah
that's mind over matter that's that's
that's a guy who's a master of his
facilities I asked how do you daddy do
he's like I just keep telling myself
dude you're so rad you're so [ __ ]
right like like Mark Wahlberg in Boogie
Nights
yeah you're [ __ ] rock star this is
the greatest that was still it to be
able to talk yourself into staying
sexually functional is amazingly
impressive like I could never talk
myself up into keeping an erection I
want to be talking myself out of it
right right right yeah you're you start
thinking about it's like oh no yeah and
so there it goes it's wilting away are
you in a relationship now are you single
I am married you are married okay I
didn't how long seven eight years when
you like when you're as famous as you
are and you get married is it one of
those things where you're like [ __ ] I'm
leaving all these people on the table
like I'm you know like yeah opportunity
at that point I was I was ready to I
just I had done that you know right so
yeah I didn't I was like I thought you
guys that's why just want to be with her
so I'm not greedy you are yeah he's
still keen will you haven't had Lee you
haven't had like like the influx that
I'm sure all the jackass guys I have not
had so no you know what I mean a steady
trickle exactly 91
started out slowly and kind of petered
out a little is a steady driven almost
30 years does she worry about you when
you're doing like because I guess you
know act the movie action point which
I've seen the trailer for like I think
it's genius because you're figuring out
how to take the essence of jackass which
is we get to watch you hurt yourself but
it's an actual film like there's it's a
narrative movie yeah like your bad
grandpa was a narrative with pranks this
is a narrative with real stunts right
and it was important to me that there
would be no cutting on the action in
this film no and all be all white angles
so you know that there's no trickery
we're going to ground and concrete and
so how seriously are you taking this are
you trying to stay in character as
you're writhing in pain or is that point
I just heard well you don't have to stay
in character because when I mean you get
you know you fly 20 feet in the air for
6 feet off the ground slam face-first
into the ground they just watch the
character do that so whatever you're
reacting is you'd react the same way but
everyone after that when I was I'm
talking about the Alpine Slide an Alpine
and slides done I did in the film and I
and I came off the track so fast fly
through the air slam so hard into the
ground
gnarly concussion eventually caused my
eye to pop out but but at the time after
I hit I start giggling because that's my
nervous reaction to pain right so
everyone thought oh he's okay right yeah
because the giggle is like oh that must
have really hurt alright let's get up
and do it again not I just broke my
orbital bone and I can custom myself
right
generally the giggle thing how many
concussions have you had I had four on
this movie oh Jesus
but I've had about 16 overall do you
worry about CTE and stuff like that I do
I've been to neurologists and talked to
them about it and I was in the middle of
getting tests after my third concussion
on this film you know I got a series of
tests and they and they had a couple
more to get but they said my brain had
effectively reset itself and then we did
a reshoot and I got another concussion
and I got two teeth so yeah I got to
start the test all over again tells you
to knock out your teeth what was the
stunt that you you got there then
last concussion and knocked out your
teeth I was doing a thing where my
character older is kind of telling his
granddaughter about the kind of a
narrative device and so we were filming
that and my character was doing a
pull-up and the bar broke on we I meant
for it to break and I meant to pull up
to my chest so if I pull it through my
chest and the bar breaks I'm going to
flat back and the bar hits me here but I
got excited and over rotated and landed
on my head and the bar hits me right in
the mouth oh wow
so I got a concussion in my teeth which
teeth this one bottom right this one in
the front way my gosh way back like
almost parallel with the roof of my
mouth do you have if you have moments on
the set where you're like I we shouldn't
why am i doing this thing mmm
I think after this film you know I I did
take a second and cuz you know I I had
before the reshoots I had lost my mom in
November and then it's like oh I got to
go do reshoots now and it was you know
so I thought about it more than I ever
had after a movie yes because it's like
do I want to make my kids feel like I'm
feeling right now you know making things
wrap up early when you don't have to by
doing crazy [ __ ] bright so does your
family react to you doing all this stuff
like your wife especially I can only
imagine my very poorly they they like
the pranks but no one in my family likes
the stunts right because I have to go to
a certain place and you know it's they
don't like it so what do you see
yourself doing if you don't want to do
this stunts key you really are getting
hurt and if after a certain age like all
right I'm getting concussions what do
you what do you want to do keep making
films but just different kind of movies
yeah I mean I can do I could he's done a
lot of movies ooh another backpack you
create another character where I prank
people I'm you know
developing some pictures that are in the
vein of what I do but you know I'm doing
documentaries so there's a world of
things I can do I just some I will
eventually have to stop doing stunts
because I didn't realize there's only so
many chances you can take you've been
docked out more than a lot of fighters
have yes yes in in a lot of even in the
foot the football like everyone has
helmets on but I'm I'm going to
I'm not wearing helmet in any of mine so
I don't know if that's better or worse
probably worse I would think worse hobby
where they speculate helmet oh yeah if
it were better they would probably have
the football players stopped wearing
helmets that would actually cause the
the leather helmets that they used to
use were when everyone was wearing them
they were safer overall because they
were just protection but then once they
switched to the modern helmets they went
from protection to being a weapon right
so it would be safer it's like boxing
would be safer if they fought
bare-knuckle because people's hands
break long before right nice thing cuz I
mean they're they tape their hands are
like bread and in so you can go longer
your hands can go longer in bare-knuckle
is kind of getting a resurgence because
of that notion
it would just be safer which is a weird
thing maybe those fights go a long time
there like some of those bare-knuckle
fights you know those like legendary
ones we were like 80 rounds a
bare-knuckle fighting oh well you
talking about in the old days yeah in
the old days boxing used to be that way
too they would go 80 a hundred rounds
and a round would end when someone get
next went get knocked down it was it
well said just every round people would
get knocked down yeah it was it was in
and then they I think eventually had to
stop that but it brought boxing the old
boxing is brutal just yeah watching
those Jim Jeffries fights and Jack
Johnson and those guys even though 50
ones from the 80s and the 70s you forget
like that last three rounds people got
really [ __ ] up yeah that's why they
40:15 yeah ray ray ban the the Dooku Kim
boom-boom Mancini fight I think that's
the reason they went from 15 rounds to
12 rounds when Mancini unfortunately you
know Dooku Kim died in the ring yeah so
we were just talking about that like
recently you know that was why won't the
sports I think it was like on live TV it
was one of those ones that everybody saw
happened I think unless I'm remembering
I watched the fight and I remember
reading about in Sports Illustrated in
that morning or the night before
deuk-gu kim had written kill or be
killed on his lampshade that's right I'm
just like wow Jesus you think of that in
a thing you're saying you don't actually
think it's go [ __ ] this is like a
literal yeah yeah I don't think he meant
literally kill yeah I think he was just
in a fighter state of mind but when that
happens it's you know it's terrible now
so what's the mental place that you have
to get in to do the stunts you're just
saying before that when you do stuff
like this your family knows that you
have to get into this space where you're
gonna be doing this what is that I just
kind of have to let go a little and know
that I've written these stunts and I
know what has to happen for us to get
the footage and so I just suppress
whatever fear I have you don't have a
magical thinking you do you'd rather
have it look good and hurt then look
faked yes do you have any any stunts
that you've done whether it's in this
movie or the jaggis days or whatever
that have been like a five-second stunt
that nobody even really talks about but
it's excruciating ly painful like you
know where it where that relationship
I'm quite what it should be
yes sometimes you'll sometimes the ones
you think are really gonna work out
don't don't work out and it sucks when
you get really hurt and that we don't
use it right yeah I remember a stunt
Ryan did Ryan done did and jackass - he
was on top of a van surfing the van and
maybe Preston drove it straight into the
water and stopped but he stopped short
so Ryan kind of just fell off the top of
the van and just hit his head on the
shallow water and it was not it was
really gnarly but and it was it was
really compelling footage but we looked
at it and we thought that that looks
really imitatable oh yeah yeah yeah and
so we didn't put it in the movie and it
really it really hurt Ryan that we
didn't put it in the movie
I mean imitatable you didn't want things
that people were gonna do right like
that's why you use contraptions and find
like a bowl and get all yeah we're fine
right or rocket right no they're not
gonna go out and make a rocket right so
yeah so we we it's just one of those
things yeah
what made you want to tell the movie
this way as opposed to just doing like a
story based movie you know what I mean
like what was it about this that you
were like I want to get back to doing
stunts and well there is a story it's
just but I mean like like you could have
done a movie where you're just telling a
story and not hurting yourself right
yeah but it's better with stunts it's
funnier with stunts and yeah and so
that's why you know I it's like what I
do right so yeah I mean it I'm called
for it it was the world called for it I
mean not the world the world in which we
were shooting the dangerous theme park
right it's his perfect setup for me to
do stunts did you like hear the stories
of this dangerous theme park or the
dangerous theme park that it could could
be based on and go like oh my god that
imagine if this happened and that
happened exactly what happened you know
someone's to me the 14-minute dock on
action park yeah that is I mean not
someone Derek freita
who produced the film with me and helped
you know come up with the story and
that's that's it yeah we both were like
that's it it's a really unique I mean
you can already see in the trailer it's
just a really unique way of doing this
because there's this realism to it
mm-hmm
because you can see that the stunts are
actually happening yeah but there's this
clear like it's it's it's like any other
comedy we're at in a way there's certain
things that are real and there's certain
things that are mixed with the storyline
and it kind of blends together and it
makes a great movie yes